this is so embarrassing but um I was
supposed to be private yeah a little
Barris I'm I'm sorry about that awkward
oh I can't Phoenix seemed totally caught
off guard on Jimmy Kimmel Live on
Tuesday when Jimmy surprised him with
this outtake from the sets of the Joker
you started
Sharon singer after dancer fashion icon
how was that yeah not a great look
Joaquin was going off on the film's a
cinematographer which he now says he
feels bad about did he call you Cher
yeah look sometimes sometimes movies get
intense cuz here a lot of people in a
small space and they're trying to find
something and they can feel intense let
me think about okay yes a bit more okay
you do that my publicist will issue a
formal statement tomorrow okay all right
now there's still no formal statement
and we get it we know filming the Batman
villain origin story was intense I
thought that it was gonna be challenging
for me as an actor if I was gonna be
challenging for the audience and that's
exciting to me you know what maybe I
always look for characters that aren't
easy to define and they're surprising
and
in many ways and so that's what this was
I came dropped 52 pounds for the role
it's kind of a cliche question when when
people are like the physical
transformation but it was so you know a
parent watching this movie
was that something that was your
decision to you know lose a ton of
weight it was something that I've done
before and I was I swore when I did it
before that never do it again but it
seemed like it was really important for
the character and I think it ended up
affecting me in ways that that I hadn't
anticipated and certainly it affects
your emotional mental state no one can
blame Joaquin if he was hangry upset but
there's also the chance that Jimmy and
Joaquin are totally pulling one over on
us
for one when Jimmy shared the clip on
Twitter he wrote quote Joaquin Phoenix
is down to clown which could just be a
reference to the movie or a hint were
being pranked never forget that Joaquin
pretended to give up acting for a
hip-hop career for like a whole year
about a decade ago all for a
mockumentary called I'm still here which
included an uncomfortable stop by a
different late-night show david
letterman's you are gonna act anymore no
why is that
I don't know
so ya don't really know what to make of
this latest talk-show moment with
Joaquin but et will keep you updated
should there be any updates that's all
for now I'm Katie Krauss and see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]